llegó la mente hablar de revista de
prensa en directo américa de france 24
repasamos la prensa internacional por
supuesto con rosa pared masdéu rosa ya
estamos a día miércoles de esta semana y
abrimos revista de prensa comentando un
extracto del programa de la televisión
rusa nos fijamos en una lista de cédula
davis en the daily beast titulado la
televisión del kremlin espera que la
desquiciada guerra de rusia en ucrania
ayude a reelegir a durant rom como es
esto bueno ahora vuelan buenos días nos
fijamos como dices en un análisis de
julia davis que se dedica a monitorear
la televisión rosa y en este caso
concreto se fija en el canal rusia uno
no confundir con el canal 1 de rusia
donde tuvo lugar la protesta de marina
oceánico va en este caso hablamos de la
que sería la segunda televisión más
vista de rusia bien pues esta periodista
parte de la premisa que cuando rusia
empezó esta invasión de ucrania gran
parte del mundo se posicionó en contra
de moscú y que por lo tanto la
televisión estatal utiliza cualquier
signo de apoyo a rusia a moscú en este
contexto bélico pues para hacer
propaganda en sus medios estatales y
particularmente usados voces
occidentales muy destacadas por un lado
el ex presidente estadounidense donald
trump y por otro lado el presentador de
la televisión estadounidense también
'fox news' tucker carlson bien según
explica este periodista pues los medios
rusos estatales habrían sido incluso
alentados por parte del kremlin a hacer
uso particularmente de estas voces
occidentales y dice la periodista dice
davis incluso tienen pensado dos
recompensas para estas dos personas no
por agradecerles esta campaña de
propaganda a favor de rusia en sus desde
sus respectivas posiciones por un lado
dicen para atacar calzone tienen
previsto concederle la codiciada
entrevista con el presidente ruso
vladimir putin y por otro lado a donald
trump pretenden hacerle pues una campaña
de relaciones públicas gratuita no de
cara a su posible reelección en las
próximas elecciones de eeuu bien está
que ocasión para comentarlo luego
entraremos más en profundidad se ha
hecho eco por ejemplo de las noticias
que destacó supuestamente el ministerio
de defensa ruso con respecto a las
cuales pues el hijo de joe biden habría
financiado un laboratorio de armas
biológicas en ucrania para atacar a
rusia etcétera algo que pues la prensa
occidental no le dio mucho crédito pero
tal cual son sino en su programa de fox
news y por otro lado a donald trump lo
usan un poco como carta con la que
atacar pues a la actual administración
de joe biden y es que digamos estos tres
actores trump calzón y la prensa los
medios estatales rusos comparten no está
enemistad por la actual administración
estadounidense de hecho nos da algunos
ejemplos no esta periodista y es que
vladimir de sólo 10 por ejemplo en una
emisión en este canal rusia 1
mostró imágenes de un bombardeo ruso en
un día mientras el presidente bailén
estaba en polonia diciendo que era una
red a las declaraciones de biden contra
putin pero si te parece raúl veamos un
fragmento que esta misma periodista
destacó en su página de twitter y que
nos muestra pues un programa presentado
por event y popov en el que pues
comentan cuál debería ser el futuro no
de la del gobierno en eeuu
no es tiempo de que nosotros nuestra
gente hagamos un llamado al pueblo
estadounidense para que cambie el
régimen en eeuu pronto sus datos y
ayudar a nuestro socio trope a
convertirse de nuevo en presidente
vamos a enfocarnos ahora a rózsa en
relación al comentaba con el presentador
de la cadena estadounidense fox news
esto que carson el mismo protagonista de
una fuerte polémica dentro de su país de
eeuu incluso el medio francés que
reseñamos aquí también media parte
dedicó un reportaje a su rol en la
narrativa de toda esta guerra
exactamente esto es un reportaje firmado
por alex visión desde nueva york donde
tuvo lugar el pasado 23 de marzo una
protesta delante de la sede de este
canal en esta ciudad estadounidense una
protesta protagonizada por
estadounidenses ucranianos ucranianos
bien hay gente que protestaba de hecho
contra el posicionamiento tomado por
este presentador de fox news respecto a
la defensa de putin en esta guerra y de
hecho otro dato que nos da este
reportaje de mediapart
esta es la emisión más vista de foxnews
por lo que el presentador digamos tiene
una cierta protección de su puesto de
trabajo a pesar de que los manifestantes
pidan su expulsión de la cadena si te
parece comentamos una cita de una de las
manifestantes que habla con el
periodista de mediapart ella dice tiene
un público muy importante es muy popular
entre sus espectadores que de hecho
también nos dice este artículo lo ven
como un posible sucesor de donald trump
dice esta chica según los abogados de
foxnews no es considerado un periodista
por lo que no está sujeto a las mismas
exigencias de veracidad sin embargo sus
seguidores lo consideran como una fuente
de información y aún así está en
posición de no tener que responder de
sus afirmaciones mientras que hay vidas
en peligro y si te parece vamos a ver un
extracto de lo que es la emisión no de
cal son en fox news un extracto que
hemos recuperado de la semana pasada
vamos a verlo
por qué no decir solamente es
intolerable que rusia haga esto y
preferimos a ucrania vamos a apoyar a
ucrania está bien pero porque este paso
de más para decirnos que ucrania es una
democracia modelo cuando no lo es en
absoluto porque hacen esto quizás porque
ocre arne tiene ahora exactamente el
tipo de democracia que les gustaría
tener aquí en eeuu también pensar que
puede ser verdad pero pregúntense si
pudieran encontrar un pretexto de
amenaza a la seguridad nacional una
guerra por ejemplo piensan que adam
schiff o kamala harris o mitch mcconnell
tardarían más de un segundo en prohibir
a sus opositores que se presentarán a
las elecciones o creen que dudarían
antes de cancelar este programa para
siempre no por supuesto que no
todo estos programas así rosa de opinión
nos digamos elena cámara dando sus
opiniones del acontecer internacional o
tiene invitados también tiene invitados
no digamos que ha habido también mucha
polémica por la forma que ha tenido de
abordar a ciertos representantes sobre
todo demócratas o republicanos pero del
ala que apoyan a byd en en su pues
respuesta a lo que está haciendo el
conflicto en ucrania pero es que
tal son digamos defiende representa más
bien esta postura republicana en contra
del intervencionismo puede ser el
exterior no de eeuu pero digamos tal y
como veíamos en este fragmento él no se
posiciona abiertamente quizás a raíz de
esta polémica a favor del kremlin no
sino que es lo que se posiciona es más
bien digamos en contra de que eeuu esté
apoyando tan abiertamente ucrania y
digamos el new york times y el
washington post han dedicado rápidamente
para concluir también artículos a esta
cuestión por un lado en el new york
times ya de cal son dice que si no se
está posicionando a favor de que eeuu
ayude a ucrania
él ya hizo desde la sien en ese momento
mucha propaganda a favor de la guerra de
la invasión de estados unidos a irak y
que ahora se arrepiente de ello pero por
otro lado en el 'washington post' para
terminar encontramos que chris wallace
un periodista también de foxnews dimitió
entre otras cosas a raíz de carlson que
dedicó un especial a decir que el asalto
al capitolio del 6 de enero fue una
ataque un acto de falsa bandera y que la
situación en fox news ya era
insostenible totalmente para poder
ejercer el periodismo rosa gracias por
toda la información nos vemos mañana con
más de revista de prensa en directo
américa pasamos a saludar a nuestra
primera invitada al día